[Music]
if you don't watch the white house press
briefings with jen saki and we
sympathize with you if you don't you may
have missed us we played it before
because it was really one of the amazing
moments in american politics not enough
people noticed it jen saki from the
podium in the white house briefing room
the other day called on joe rogan's boss
spotify to censor joe rogan here's what
she said
this disclaimer it's a positive step but
we want every platform to continue doing
more to call out misinformants and
disinformation while also uplifting
accurate information but ultimately uh
you know our viewers it's a it's a it's
a good step it's a positive step but
there's more that can be done so what
the apologists have told us for the past
four years as we point out censorship
after censorship after censorship book
burning it's all totally fine because
the government's not doing this has been
national reviews position for five years
as long as not the government
then really says david french the first
amendment doesn't apply
but here you have the government the
president's own spokes chick demanding
censorship and then the company obing
spotify has removed 70 episodes of joe
rogan's show
so this seems like a crime actually
but what do we know we're not lawyers
glenn greenwald is he's also an
independent journalist he joins us
tonight glenn thanks so much for coming
on so they've been telling us all this
time like it's no big deal settle down
glenn greenwald this is not a violation
the first amendment whatever it is
this looks like a violation the first
amendment
right and obviously that that comment
that you just referenced is in and of
itself disturbing why should the white
house be weighing in at all on who they
think should be on spotify who they
think should not be what they think
spotify shouldn't shouldn't be doing
about their podcast podcastos but it's
even more alarming when you consider
that it's actually part of a broad
pattern even an explicit strategy by
democrats to use their majoritarian
power in washington to coerce companies
to censor for them in ways the
constitution would prohibit they've
repeatedly subpoenaed social media
companies and explicitly said if you
don't start censoring more you will face
legal and regulatory reprisals remember
when parlor was taken off the internet
when it was the number one most popular
downloaded app it was because aoc went
online the day before and said hey
google and apple and wall street and
and amazon why are you allowing this app
that i don't like on the internet and
three days later it was gone so this is
exactly the kind of coercion tucker
that the supreme court has said the
first amendment that the government
can't engage in without violating the
first amendment it's just so strange
that lawmakers in the so-called
opposition party sit back like there's
nothing we can do
you know these are private businesses
but as you just pointed out these are
not private businesses acting
independently they're acting
in response to the threats of government
which regulates them
i think this is one of the key most
overlooked parts of the whole censorship
debate is these silicon valley companies
never set out to want to censor why
would they why would you want to kick
people off your platform you want more
people on your platform and
ideologically they came out of silicon
valley which is about the free internet
so why are they now doing it it's in
part because they got pressured by
journalists the new york times and nbc
saying if you don't censor you have
blood on your hands and you're
responsible for the destruction of
democracy but a big reason is they know
that democrats will
start enacting laws and enforcing
regulation against them if they don't
censor more and they know that because
democrats are saying it explicitly over
and over
and there's no one they'd like to censor
more than you glenn greenwald on sub
stack to be clear great to see you
tonight thank you